I was born to rule the Seven Kingdoms
and I will the rules already begun I
drawn first blood first it will be ready
they know we're coming
you
hey everybody it's finally happening
John snow is finally meeting Daenerys so
if you're brand new to the channel be
sure to subscribe to get everything this
season there are also a couple of things
that I want to address from episode 2
that I just didn't fit into my video
there's so many things to pick over we
could talk about the episodes all day
long but they're really like a couple
big plot lines that unfold in this
trailer the only thing you don't see a
lot of are Jamie with his soldiers at
Highgarden
most of the Highgarden stuff we're
saying seems like after we've won the
battle in most of the Lannister soldiers
that we're seeing or actually from
Casterly Rock when the unsullied try to
sack it so one you have unsullied using
the mass rapid transit system to go all
the way around the bottom here and up to
Casterly Rock
looks like they escaped you're on for
those that are wondering about the ships
of Daenerys --is that were destroyed
during the Greyjoy battle those are just
the Greyjoy's ships that Yara and Theon
stole from Euron they still have all
those ships that the unsullied were on
you just think of them as the ships that
they stole from the wise masters
Daenerys his fleet was cobbled together
from a couple different sources so
they've only lost like a giant portion
of it but they still do have some ships
that are left and because Euron was so
myopic about going after the gift that
he wanted to get for Cersei like these
sand snakes here it sounds like either
he didn't know or he wasn't worried
about the unsullied either way they make
it around and it's going to be one of
the big action set pieces of the episode
in addition to Jaime down at Highgarden
these archers actually might be from
down at Highgarden because you see
Jaime's standing behind them in these
other shots from the previous trailers
the other side of that is you're on
returning to King's Landing getting his
hero's welcome if you saw this out of
context you might actually think that
you're on was a really good person like
oh you know he did something really good
everybody is cheering him on this is
great but you know he's one of the worst
human beings on the show now that
Ramsay's gone Cersei and Euron are going
to be so wonderfully terrible together
they deserve each other I can't wait to
watch that snake eat its own tail the
other side of this obviously like the
big thing that most people are probably
going to be talking about after the
episode is Jon Snow and Davos going to
Dragonstone and then beginning the
process of him just working with
Daenerys however that's going to play
out I was making all those fanfiction
jokes on my episode 2 video Mel
sandra shows up and tells her about the
legend of john snow
you must summon him he has a role to
play as do you
the prince or princess who was promised
but the way the actors have been over
hyping the drama even though you know
the end point you know obviously they're
going to work together it's not going to
start out with them immediately
understanding everything that they need
to do the places they need to be so
Daenerys doesn't know anything about Jon
Snow others in Tyrion vouched for him
she's aware of the red God she knows a
little bit about his teachings but she
doesn't follow the red God she's not
necessarily a believer even though she's
had all these supernatural experiences
she's even seen visions of the coming of
the night King in the house of the
undying remember when she was seeing
King's Landing in ruins in the middle of
winter then she sees a vision of the
gate at Castle black raising up she sees
beyond the wall this white haze coming
upon her she's seeing the coming of the
long night so they haven't been very
clear about how much she believes in
what she saw or what she thinks of it
she hasn't spent a whole lot of time
talking about it but presumably that's
what we're going to get Jon Snow coming
in talking about the army of the Dead
trying to give her more practical
explanation but the real question is
though is that if that's the endpoint of
the season is this big battle they're
hyping up at eastwatch-by-the-sea the
waves are frozen and we're only in
episode three what's going to be
happening during episodes four five in
the early part of six so it's going to
be fun to watch Jon Snow and Daenerys
his relationship evolved over that time
like if they start out like Jon and
Sansa right now just sort of sniping at
each other or if they have this mutual
respect because she's a queen like Jon
Snow said she'll only listen to another
king so that's why he chose to go
himself but I feel like even though
their storyline is the big mythology pay
off the more practical pay off like in
the way that your ons big action set
piece in this last week's episode was
the big payoff is going to be Highgarden
in Casterly Rock so if you're a big fan
of episodes like Battle of the bastards
in seeing Jamie Lannister mode through
people like actually seeing Jamie do
something really badass then episode 3
is going to be your episode like he's
not going to be completely invincible
this season but I think what we'll see
is that because he was hyping up randyll
Tarly is this a Mae
in general is that Jamie will slowly
rise to the occasion like you have all
these younger characters that look up to
the older characters and even though
Jamie's previously had a really good
reputation as an awesome fighter people
haven't taken him very seriously
especially since he's been the
Kingslayer and he lost his hand so
you're slowly seeing the redemption of
Jamie over the course of the season
while you're slowly watching Cersei
spiral down into the black pit of evil
but one of the best things about Game of
Thrones is the actual playing of the
game of Thrones like the politicking in
the way the Game of Thrones does it so
well so we get a lot of that we get a
lot of the big battles and then we have
Arya Stark in brand who might make it to
Winterfell in Episode three it's hard to
tell how fast bran is moving but it
sounds like santa's walking away from
the heart tree here bran might be behind
her so just remember that those things
are happening in the background we did
follow up with Arya it seems like she's
moving pretty fast if the unsullied can
make it all the way around to Westeros
and get to Casterly Rock in a single
episode then bran and Arya can probably
make it back to Winterfell on that same
amount of time too but I believe the
episode is a little bit longer than
normal so I'm expecting us to follow up
with Sir Jorah as well at least for a
couple minutes just to address what
happens next with him like how they
continue to treat the greyscale make
sure that it doesn't come back and it
really does seem like with all the
history that they're teasing like the
Samwell book he says should we pick a
more poetic title yes he is talking
about you know big eye wink calling the
book that maester ebro's is writing a
song of ice and fire like they're
literally writing a song of ice and fire
the events that happen after Robert's
rebellion on the show so I'll be
interested to see if that's something
completely out of the mind of Dan and
Dave or if george RR martin always
intended to include a joke like that but
it does kind of feel like something that
Dan and Dave went rogue on like we're
going to include this wing to the books
George our Martin does write a lot of
fictional books within the world of Game
of Thrones like there are a lot of books
that pop up books about dragons books
about history but typically they have
the more dry titles that Ebro suggested
to Samwell before Samwell dumped on it
and suggested a more poetic title so
wouldn't it be funny if Samwell is the
one to actually finish that book Samwell
himself after all this is
said and done starts writing a song of
ice and fire and it's just a history of
the things that we've been seeing since
the end of Robert's rebellion but maybe
that's a little too Lord of the Rings
because Bilbo Baggins there and back
again it's the exact same thing but
people always compare talking to George
R Martin even though Martin tries to
avoid comparisons like that but let me
know in the comments what do you most
hype about for next week but what's
going to happen next is I have a couple
more Comic Con videos to get through
I'll post my Game of Thrones episode to
Q&A on Tuesday so leave all your
questions in the comments below and
leave all your bonus video requests too
now that we're getting on in the episode
there's so many more things that we need
to talk about but congratulations to the
latest giveaway winner Lilith the black
please private message me on the back
end of my channel so I can get your
contact details you can click here for
my episode 2 video and you can click
here for my season 7 playlist thank you
so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight